how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the mcu now with
one division coming out in january
there's been a lot of promotion for the
show lately there's been a lot of
interviews done by the cast and crew
and kevin feige who has recently
revealed some very interesting things
about wanda's character and some things
that might happen
in the one division series and of course
we're all hoping that we'll get another
trailer for the series before it comes
out which we should
possibly late december or maybe even
early january
but as of right now the release date has
not changed and the show is coming out
on january 15th we know that it's going
to be a pretty
wild show and perhaps the most exciting
thing that we can look forward to
is wanda actually becoming the scarlet
witch
now we've been told by marvel that she's
finally going to be called the scarlet
witch in the series
but the question is how exactly does she
become
the scarlet witch well it involves some
mutants
the sorcerer supreme a demon and a lot
of chaos magic
so we'll break down what we know and
what marvel studios as president kevin
feige has told us in a recent interview
in this video if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a black widow
funko pop from the avengers game
provided by heroeshideout.com
so to start off there's a few very
interesting facts that come from marvel
studios as president kevin feige that he
revealed in a recent interview
now in this article with empire magazine
it says that elizabeth olsen's character
aka the scarlet witch might have proved
she was more powerful than we were ever
aware of at the end of avengers in game
but audiences are about to understand
her a whole lot better
including what exactly she can do with
those mind stone imbued powers
and then it quotes kevin feige saying if
you look at the infinity saga
i don't think any single person has gone
through more pain and trauma than wanda
maximoff
and no character seems to be as powerful
as wanda maximoff
sidenote this is kevin feige seemingly
confirming that wanda is indeed the
strongest character in the mcu but he
continues to say
and no character has a power set that is
as ill-defined and unexplored as wanda
maximoff
so it seemed exploring that would be
worthwhile
post-endgame who else is aware of that
power
where did it come from did the mine
stone unlock it
so those three questions at the end are
extremely important and pretty revealing
and we'll start with the first question
who else is aware
of that power now in the comics wanda is
indeed a mutant an omega
level mutant but however her chaos
magical powers were given to her by the
demon chathan
now the demon chathan could show up in
the wanda vision series and he also
could show up in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
but remember this is the mcu they don't
exactly copy the comic books page for
page
in fact they do like to change things up
and there's been a lot of rumors going
around that the demon that is actually
going to show up
is a fisto in fact it's been said that
evan peters is confirmed to have a role
in the one division series and a lot of
people think that that role
is indeed the demon mephisto now as some
of you may know he has
a very big connection to wanda in the
comics when wanda magically gets
pregnant
and has her two twin boys she would go
on to find out that they were actually
the shards of the spirit of the demon
mephisto
and she ends up taking them back and
loses her kids and this sends her down a
very dark path that would ultimately
lead to the house of
m storyline now could mephisto actually
be responsible for giving her her powers
that's unclear at this point and it
would kind of be an unnecessary retcon
however we go back to kevin feige's
question who else is aware of that power
that the scarlet witch has
it definitely seems like it is going to
be him especially when you consider that
doctor strange is confirmed to appear in
the one division series
dealing with demons is kind of what
doctor strange does
so this makes perfect sense that he's
going to have to come into the one
division series to help
wanda deal with mephisto and also
control her powers
now the last two questions go hand in
hand but are very important
where did it come from speaking of her
powers and did the mind stone
unlock it now in the movies it was said
that the mind stone
did give them their powers it didn't say
they unlocked any powers it said that it
gave them their powers
but now all of a sudden the president of
marvel studios is asking the rhetorical
question
did the mind stone unlock her powers and
he's also saying
where did they come from so he is now
getting us to question
something that marvel studios has
actually already stated
so this means this is kevin feige saying
wanda didn't actually get her powers
from the mind stone they actually unlock
something
and of course for us fans waiting for
the mutants and the x-men to come into
the mcu we can only think of one thing
the x-gene the mutant gene typically the
x-gene lies dormant inside of mutants
until awoken and then they start to
exhibit their mutant powers
so essentially the question that kevin
feige is asking and getting us to think
about
is that did she have the x gene and did
the mind stone unlock
and awaken her mutant x gene this is
seemingly how they're going to introduce
the mutants and the x-men into the mcu
stating that they actually had the gene
the whole entire time
but perhaps the snap awoken some of the
x genes inside some people so it looks
like
wanda is in fact going to be a mutant in
the one division series
so how exactly is the true scarlet witch
going to come into play
well there are a couple of characters
that are seemingly going to help wanda
develop her powers
even further one is agatha harkness now
a lot of people seem to think that she's
going to be a villain of the series
that perhaps it's her that is creating
all of these different realities for
wanda and possibly even trapping her
inside and certainly in the comics she
has warped with wanda's reality a little
bit but it was for her own good
you see agatha harkness for the most
part in the comics is a good person who
definitely cares about wanda
in the comics she trains her and she
teaches her about her powers
she's also trusted by the fantastic four
to take care of franklin richards the
son of sue storm
and reed richards so although there is
definitely room for agatha harkness to
be a villain in the one division series
it's more likely that she's going to be
a good person
a good witch who is going to help wanda
become a good witch as well a very
powerful witch
the scarlet witch and then of course
doctor strange is confirmed to be in the
wanda vision series
now of course he is the master of the
mystic arts he knows a lot of different
spells and he knows how to help
wanda control her powers and grow them
and this is where seemingly the darkhold
is going to come in
now the darkhold's origin goes back to
the demon i mentioned that gave wander
her powers in the comics the demon
chathan
chauthon was a demonic elder god who was
earth's first practitioner of blackmagic
he wrote the book he put all of his
collected knowledge about magic
into this book and the book is so
powerful that even the wizard merlin
and saint brendan could not control it
or destroy it
well wanda learning this type of magic
will definitely give her a huge power
boost
in the mcu wanda has kind of only messed
around with her own chaos magic
abilities she hasn't exactly used any
spells
but now she's going to have agatha
harkness and doctor strange who are
going to be there to help her
learn different types of spells and
different ways to control her powers
now this alone would give wanda a very
big power boost and according to kevin
feige she's already the most powerful
character in the mcu
this could finally earn her her title of
the scarlet witch which she has in the
comics
alone but we know that there's going to
be more there's going to be something
that sends wanda
over the edge to completely bring out
the scarlet witch in her and
unfortunately it's probably going to be
the loss of her children
now we've seen her kids wicken and speed
in the trailer but as i mentioned in the
comics mephisto wants them back and he
takes them back
and what happens after that is a very
long and awesome story but to put it
simply
wanda slowly starts to go insane until
eventually she creates the house of m
reality where mutants rule the world and
magneto
and the scarlet witch along with
quicksilver and her two children
rule the world now this is true scarlet
witch power and although i don't think
she's going to be ruling the world in
the one division series
i do think that she's going to want and
try to get her kids back which is where
i think doctor strange is going to come
in and try and help
and from here where she's devastated at
the loss for kids and absolutely over
the top angry
i think that's when we'll see her
explode on the demon mephisto or another
villain
to fight and get her kids back and
that's when i think we're going to get
the true
scarlet witch that we've been waiting
for the omega level mutant with
chaos reality warping magic the scarlet
witch there is a ton of stuff to be
excited for and a lot of stuff we're
anticipating for the one division series
but let me know in the comments down
below how excited you are to finally see
the true scarlet witch
on screen be sure to let me know in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe
stay up to date on all the latest mcu
news for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you